[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this episode of
you made it weird is with the incredible
Marianne Williamson here's a little
taste I found 90 of the time in my life
the best device I can give myself is get
over yourself
this is so inconsequential to the larger
things that are happening in this world
uh look at what's happening in Iran look
at what's happening in Afghanistan look
at what's happening get over yourself
and it does help you have a greater uh
willingness
to be a person who can handle who can
sweat this don't sweat the small stuff
so excited that Marianne is here you
guys are going to love this chat I sure
did obviously Marianne is a American
Author best-selling author number one
best-selling author a spiritual leader
and a former and possibly future
Presidential nominee so it was a thrill
to get to sit down with her I'm so
excited for you guys to hear this
episode just a couple things to plug up
top one of which is I am currently on
tour if you would like to see me
actually let me get the dates let me get
those sweet sweet dates uh because we
just added a whole bunch of cities I'm
doing my new hour of stand up I'll be in
Atlanta Charlotte North Carolina
Washington DC Vancouver Grand Rapids San
Diego New Orleans Dallas Houston
Milwaukee Madison Wisconsin Royal Oak
Michigan Minneapolis New York New York
and finally Connecticut uh it's it's a
great tour I'm really excited about this
hour it's extra good because the
quarantine shut things down I've been
working on this one longer and I'm going
to say I think it's my best one yet very
excited and thank you to all the weirdos
that have come out so far so go to
petehomes.com if you'd like to see me
out on the road this episode is brought
To Us by our friends at Living Libations
living Libations is a high-end Natural
Hair Skin teeth eyes whatever you have
they have a beauty product a skin care
product a self-care product that is made
with ingredients that you will recognize
for years I've been careful about what I
put in my body but I wasn't being very
careful about what I put on my body when
it comes to like moisturizers shaving
creams aftershave
Gum Care stuff like this I just was
buying what they had at the pharmacy or
Worse some weird kiosk at the mall and I
thought it was high-end I thought it was
nice I thought it was good quality what
because it had a French name or maybe
because it was expensive but of course
these products are filled with chemicals
and toxicity levels that were just not
intended for human consumption and make
no mistake if you're putting something
in your hair or on your skin it's
getting absorbed into your bloodstream
it's getting into your body so this
stuff was not intended for human
consumption it's not made for humans
it's weird so if you want to replace
these items in your medicine cabinet in
your shower with a beautiful not only a
beautiful powerful effective product
with ingredients that you can recognize
and a natural quality that you will see
and feel the difference but actually
super super powerful products meaning
not some like watered-down hippie
version of a product but a badass
effective version that's made with stuff
that you can read those ingredients and
feel good about living Libations is here
to save your day and your skin and your
hair and your teeth and your nails
whatever it is this is a great way to
support the show because they have lots
of small things so you can show your
support of the show by getting yourself
a tongue scraper at Living Libations or
you can do a complete like Val and I did
complete overhaul of all of your
products and become distant living
Libations house that's what that's what
we've done a good example of how
effective these are they're exfoliant
scrub exfoliating scrub not only is it
made with stuff that you will know
you'll know everything on that
ingredient list it's way more it's got
more grit and more exfoliating power
than any exfoliant I've ever used in my
life and pro tip baked right into this
ad uh it's super important to exfoliate
before you shave I don't know if you
guys are having a hard time or getting
razor burn a huge Pro tip is exfoliate
before you shave and if you you use
their Ginger exfoliating scrub you're
going to get more dead skin cells off
and a cleaner clear shave I'm sure that
would be true for if you're shaving your
legs as well I just shave my face so
I'll tell you that it works for my face
plants oils extracts that you recognize
is real and natural and it works like
the Zen shave is the bomb that they make
that I use to shave it's so clean and
natural and moisturizing you can
actually use a dab of it as your
aftershave try doing that with some
weird Anonymous neon green blue goo you
shoot out of a pressurized can and at
night boat Val and I use their best skin
ever moisturizer smells great feels
great keeps your skin looking great and
healthy and vibrant and Alive we use
that before bed but it's wonderful if
you can support the show and living
Libations is a great great way to do it
whatever you need to replace Skin Body
baby if you have a baby or a child we
lather in the summer months Leela in
their love the sun zinc based uh
sunblock because it's actually natural
so hard that you type in natural
sunblock online you find a bunch of ones
that aren't actually natural for some
reason it's a loophole they call
themselves natural living Libations will
give you the real deal the real natural
one that is and filled with toxic stuff
so go to livinglibations.com weird you
don't have to use a promo code anymore
just go to
livinglibations.com weird and you'll get
15 off and you'll show your support of
this show we're also brought To Us by
our friends at on it the makers of Alpha
Brain you guys know I swear by new
atropics and Alpha Brain is my must-have
go-to nootropic what is a new atropic
it's Earth grown ingredients that help
your brain do what it needs to do I'm
talking about memory I'm talking about
concentration I'm talking about Focus
for me creative work for the past six
seven years now eight years I haven't
done a podcast I haven't written a
script I haven't acted in a TV show or a
movie I haven't even gone out on a date
or sometimes just take a couple I don't
even have anything to do that day
because I want my brain to be
functioning at its highest level it's
not a stimulant it's not like caffeine
it doesn't get you up it's just it's
like food for your brain I think of uh
goldfish are like your ideas Alpha Brain
is sprinkling food onto that on the top
of the water for your ideas to nibble on
and come to I'm going to say it fruition
Alpha Brain has been a huge huge help in
my creative life but also just my social
life if you want your brain working well
I wish I knew about this in in school
I'm so glad I know about it now I have
it in the pockets of my coats I have it
in my car I have it in my travel bag
Alpha Brain has absolutely changed my
life for the better if you like it one
tenth as much as I do you're about to
[__] your pants give it a try they have
it in powder form they have it in pill
form it's absolutely wonderful go to on
it o n n i t.com slash weird you'll get
10 off everything you see on that
landing page that's on it.com slash
weird alright everybody
enjoy Marianne Williamson hope to see
you on the road peterhomes.com all right
get into it I'm thrilled to meet you I
really am thank you thank you for coming
in thank you for having me yeah we were
saying off mic a little bit you saw the
pictures of ROM dust and I was happy I I
wasn't surprised and that's Richard
rohr's hat right there
you know Richard as well as well yeah he
gave me that hat
[Laughter]
which was his and it's my Little Richard
Roy Relic overlooking my uh my desk what
what are your what's your connection to
romness
well or your relationship with him
I know him you know
first of all years before I actually
knew him uh be here now was such a an
important book for my generation that
was what we all read and then later of
course just because of the work I do I
knew him he really changed after his
stroke and he became
he had been a bit of a tough guy
and after his stroke he became very very
sweet yeah no I I can attest to
post-stroke ramdas is my favorite
romance yeah yeah because he's an Aries
not I'm not a huge astrology person he
was an heiress he's an Aries I'm also an
Aries I didn't know that but I'm not
surprised and I don't know what he is on
the Enneagram but my personal feeling
was he might have been an achiever but
I'm also well you mentioned Richard
Moore so Richard Moore would probably
know ROM das's anywhere I've never I
don't know if it's ever come up although
Richard is wrong and Richard always says
I'm a seven and I am not a seven
although a seven I like to say a seven
hosts this show I don't uh I don't have
a natural I don't grok the Enneagram the
way I do like astrology and other
systems oh really you're more I mean it
always sounds interesting but it's not a
like I'll hear one and go oh that's me
and then I'll go no that's me and then
somebody says well no it's the wings and
all that and I just get bored before I
figure it out yeah
being I guess it was sort of like a
humbling from the from this oh the
stroke oh
he he
was so sweet that that the younger uh
ROM Das was a tough guy in a way do you
have any did you meet him as before the
stroke or was it just happening yeah you
knew him before
yeah how are you introduced you read me
here now well I do that kind of work you
know no I'm I'm not sure
yeah I don't know who how it all
originally I remember when I had been
invited to
actually to do something at the White
House and I called them to ask him
what he thought and if he thought I
should go no they're all a bunch of you
know he was he was kind of very wow
really but once again he became someone
very different yeah yeah I do that that
was my experience that was the view I
did a couple private Retreats with him
where I don't know if you knew that he
did that later in his life Hawaii were
you in Hawaii yeah that's where I last
saw him and sit with him which was super
yeah and he came to a talk I did in
Hawaii and he was just in a wheelchair
and he was
sweet yeah it's funny one of the reasons
I'm so thrilled to talk with you is
because I I'm on I think I'm less than
71. of course America yeah I'm really
into it yeah I'm very very excited and I
was like we need to have somebody on the
show and of course you're the first name
that comes up thank you but yeah no and
you're brilliant when you talk about it
so you couldn't be talking to somebody
more excited oh thank you so much share
this time with you yeah what's lesson
71. lesson 71 is God's uh I might get
the wording a little bit wrong but it's
God's plan for salvation is the only one
oh yeah the idea that God's plan for
salvation will work and yours won't and
the egos won't yeah it's really I mean I
find that like 65 to 7 where I am right
now has just been real fire and amazing
stuff well it's a very specific
curriculum in the dismantling the first
half of the year is dismantling a
thought system based on fear yeah and
the second half is is replacing that
with a thought system based on love it's
a lot it's a lot like being a the gym
with a trainer yes they know which
specific exercises and weights and all
of that for specific
um it's a curriculum right and uh but
that idea of God's plan for salvation is
opposed to mine is obviously a big one
because the Western mind we're trained
to thinking that you know I gotta go get
what I want in life and make it happen
and the orientation of the Course in
Miracles is much more Eastern and feel
less about making it happen more about
allowing it to happen so when you have
this got to go first of all you know
gotta go take the bull by the horns well
that's a suicidal thing to do so and
typically right yeah it's just a
terrible idea yeah not a good idea
um the idea of allowance of angels
pushing you from behind the idea that
you you don't plan the future
you a lot you program the future you
plan the future is very different than
you program the future the way to
program the future is by living very
fully in this moment so the Western mind
would say well I'm sitting here talking
to Pete what could I get out of this and
what should I what should I make this be
that maybe will serve me later yeah
that's the corruption of the ego mind
and I have to lose and you have to win
that sort of idea well I wouldn't even
necessarily I mean I could still see it
as hopefully I hope he gets something
out of it too sure but just the idea
that I'm this is just a way to get me
somewhere else right as opposed to if I
will show up fully in this moment as
best I can for whatever might be a
sharing of good energy the future will
take care of itself for sure that's a
very different orientation to the Future
right I guess what what I meant by the I
have to I don't think you're trying to
beat me but one of the things I think
the course is good at pointing out is
that it's a win-win Universe yeah killer
be killed yeah well because there's only
one of us here
in the course's perspective there's only
one of us here yeah so so that's why
it's showing up for you I am showing up
for myself completely agree that's why I
wanted to give you a hug I wanted to
make you feel so welcome because it is
just us but in the ego's thoughts so
today's lesson is like the ego system
there are a couple things that it
mentioned one was that it doesn't work
and that it's not it's designed not to
work do you remember well not only is it
designed not to work it's denied to
right it is it's not neutral it's like
alcoholism it's not here to
inconvenience you it's here to kill you
you know it's a progressive like I said
about an AAA it's a progressive disease
addiction is Progressive cancer is
Progressive yeah I mean inertia means
the tendency of the object to move in
whatever Direction it's been moving
unless and until there's a direction of
a counter Force so we like to think well
my thoughts are neutral I'm not allowed
to to hurt anybody well actually if
you're not proactively there to help
somebody do we have service to love yeah
there's no such thing as a neutral
thought it's either a thought a
proactive light or of an Insidious
darkness and that's another course thing
that really stood out to me I I'm just
so thrilled to be talking to somebody
that that knows it so well it's really
exciting for me talking about like even
a mild grievance is the same like
there's no difference it like and that's
a big one for all of us but but when I
read this sort of stuff I was like oh my
God this is what I've been waiting for I
I it's it's Fierce does that make sense
like I was waiting for something fierce
I joke with my friends I go this is
metal like the music metal oh I always
say New Age spa music it's like it's
like acid to burn away illusion I always
say of Course in Miracles is God for
smart people well of course yeah this
isn't this is not spa music here that's
what these people say oh it's just
something to help people cope well it's
not always so comfortable but that issue
better the grievance is so major to the
course you can have a grievance or you
can have a miracle you cannot have both
right and even a small grievance well
you know I I think of it in terms of
like a shadow across the Sun it could be
my hat or it could be a building either
way if it's a shadow it's a shadow right
um and as you said any thought so you
really the course of Miracle says you
achieve so little because you have an
undisciplined mind so you start not only
disciplining Behavior but even your
thoughts yeah even your thoughts yeah
like oh
he's blah blah blah that's gonna corrupt
something and how you show up in a
situation if I if I walk into a business
meeting or any situation at all and I'm
carrying judgmental thoughts about who's
going to be there and I don't clear that
yep then I heard you on Oprah say that
you got to blast them with love which I
did for you by the way oh thank you
Marion's coming I'm opening my heart and
you kind of feel it you there's a
there's a body that's a correlation that
you feel this spaciousness opening up we
all know you walk into a place and it's
like this kind of bad energy you kind of
feel the yeah sure you know everybody
subconsciously knows everything because
all minds are joined so if you walk into
a place and you you come with a kind of
radical Goodwill you come with a kind of
Namaste Consciousness people tend to
like you more they won't necessarily
know why yeah but they're more at home
with you because you've made a place for
them in your own heart it's funny I
remember before I got more spiritual I
remember reading some Tony Rob and stuff
for listening to Tony Robbins and he was
talking about try to picture how you you
want a meeting to go picture them
laughing or smiling or whatever it was
that seems to be like a baby step in the
direction of what we're talking about
well what you just described is fun you
see them laughing or whatever but too
much of that mentality is
sales and exploitation because it's
about okay how many units of your
product do you want to sell at this
meeting and how much of me do I want
them to buy right well yeah but let's
stay with a product issue for a moment
if we might so a lot of that says
imagine how many
units of this product you want us I want
to sell you know sell at this meeting
and I'm going to have that in my mind
well really that's directing your
subconscious mind to manipulate the
person in whatever way possible to make
your sale that's very different you know
I think people don't necessarily realize
when you say may God's will be done God
is love and will is thought so if you go
into any situations just my God's will
be done may love Prevail here then that
which is best for you and that which is
best for me will by definition occur if
I can't honestly let's say in that sales
meeting if I don't honestly believe that
this product might
help your life then I shouldn't be in
this job you know many years ago back in
the 1980s early 1980s I had a bookstore
and in those days it was before
everything was online and the the
publishing salesman sales reps would
come to the bookstore and explain to the
um Bookseller what the new books for the
season were in order to try to sell them
and there was this one guy and I don't
remember what publisher was it was a
major publisher but I remember how much
I looked forward to it he had read all
the books and he would tell me and I was
so fortunate to be uh have a career and
still do in a gentleman's business the
publisher wins the reader wins and the
author wins there doesn't have to be any
exploitation there it's it's really
everybody you know the publisher invests
money the writer invests effort the
reader invest everybody leaves with
value right so that that's what sales
should be like I have this this might be
good for you and I don't want you to
take it if it's not good for you so the
sort of unfettered capitalists you know
stuff that we're also aware of these
days is one of which I'll tell you
anything I need to tell you uh to get
you to buy my product and that's
obviously led to
consequences in our society where we
treat other people that way everything's
like Tinder everything's exploit
everything's manipulate everything's
what can you do for me yeah pardon me
everything does become a lie yeah well
it's like designed obsolescence comes to
mind well that's another strange thing
that we've just taken that's just normal
like my the charger in the bottom of my
iPhone just isn't working I was like
this has happened before and this is why
I bought an old iPhone and isn't it
strange it's not strange that a
corporation does it because I can
understand how that could become insane
but it's weird that we've forgiven it
not in the good way I agree it's weird
that we're just like that's normal I
agree I really agree with that things
don't last yeah and they're not supposed
to last because I'm programmed to have
to buy a new one right no you're
absolutely right and as a woman we feel
that you know what do you mean this uh
obsolescent at a certain age you know oh
yeah the disposal men don't experience
that the way we do I wonder if that is
unconsciously why we accept the
deflowering forgive the term but the
flowering of your iPhone that is the
beautiful things are supposed to crash
in fade and then we buy new ones like we
get Mysteries well yeah I mean if a
woman if there's that age of the
proverbial untuckable then that gives
the man permission to go for the younger
version right so isn't our Bible I don't
think that we don't say that about you
we don't say that about men at what age
does he become no I know Jeff Bridges
just looks great he still looks I know
my wife and I were just talking about
this like when you have children the
idea that the woman has been used or
something like it's been clean like the
idea of deflowering I I know a
deflowering thing had to do with
virginity yeah I know but what happens
when you lose your virginity that is
what they used to call deflowering
yeah for sure but like that we just had
a great conversation about that but I
wonder if our biology is sort of
reflecting the way that we look at
Commerce the way that we look at
consumerism oh oh my God
yeah every well but that's I mean every
single I mean if you look at what's
happening now with the algorithms with
the especially on social media how we're
all just trained to for our eyes to go
to the thing where there has been a
profit Center based on my suffering or
based on my feeling that I'm not enough
unless I get this or that and like I
said it's not just that it has become so
core to the way our economic system
operates it becomes core too much to how
we operate as people we're auditioning
each other these days more than we're
relating to each other sometimes what
can you do for me is almost built into
the
um built into the to the system but
that's what happens if you go into any
situation thinking okay what's my
intention here what do I want to have
happen I don't know maybe people really
know each other like each other and see
if some good will can be generated right
that's why selling out doesn't exist
anymore have you noticed that yeah oh no
selling out is considered just like
modus operandi you're considered you're
considered like
what are you talking about if if you say
anything else no we have a soulless
economic model at this point where any
kind of public ethics has been thrown uh
to the Wayside and of course at that
point any kind of personal ethics as
well yeah that's right because they're
intertwined yeah I just you know I'm a
comedian I don't know if you know but
like I was doing a joke about how our
phones are listening to us and I
jokingly say the Illuminati is making
the like just because people know that
means the people that don't have your
best interest of course I'm joking but
it's like the idea that their phones
listen to us is one thing because we see
that but the idea that we don't really
care well you know that's interesting
that you say that I do care and you can
you know it the Chinese is you know
scarier to me than the Illuminati
um the issue here of course is that I
have an incident because of my age I
have an Institutional memory of a time
when people would go what the [__] what
is this I can't even take my battery out
of my phone because I have a memory of a
time when people would have realized
this isn't how it's supposed to be yeah
you're right now young people don't even
have a memory of a time when
you could unplug a phone yeah well not
just unplugging but you could take the
battery out and all that but just of a
time when the level of not only
surveillance but
all kinds of limitation on on really
individual liberty
but because it was turned into what
about this attitude your phone is
listening to you but then your ads are
better like I catch sometimes well I
don't feel that way but young people go
like oh the algorithm studying my every
swipe my every Linger on Instagram but
then I get an ad I don't feel this way I
get an ad that's catered to what I'm
pausing at like I pause more at dog so
they're saying that's better I see an
attitude even if it's unconscious or
unspoken that young people are kind of
like well who cares I mean then they
have some things to think about the one
that kills me is not just my swipe I
have had two experiences that really
blew my mind that I noticed the phone
was in the other room
and my girlfriend said I have a
girlfriend who's at the house and she
said uh where'd you get that that
furniture I said I bought it at this
place she said what's the company I said
I don't know I'll go look in the drawer
my phone was two rooms away and the next
day I got an ad or later that day I
can't remember got an ad for that
company and that happened me also at a
dinner party I was at where my phone was
in the kitchen
that's that's really scary yeah it's not
just tracking what I'm
um you know what I'm swiping or clicking
into it's
listening to me I you know the
implications of this are so outrageous
and I think when you say people who say
well what difference does it make it's
people can't the whole thing seems so
huge how do you fight that yeah I think
there is an overwhelm and then a give up
like what can you do I'm in this maze I
might as well and that's that's where we
are and that's what's so dangerous about
this moment in history we're almost
giving ourselves over to an increasingly
dystopian social reality and that that
social reality yeah I was just going to
say that the idea that Instagram becomes
life like this whole AI conversation you
know I was noticing on the new uh
program on my computer okay
every time you upgrade and stuff so I'm
a writer and I'm writing a book and the
um there's a little blue line and so I
check it well it's suggesting better
grammar and at first I thought you know
I don't
I don't need this and then I started
noticing well this is really smart
really is like and I had read did you
read Andrew Yang's book
um war against normal yeah it came out
during the last election season war
against normal people I think
it's really good uh I think it was a
bestseller it was really good and he
talks about
um
uh how AI he said you think you're in a
job that no one could replace give you
an example stand-up comedy you probably
think uh well hey I couldn't you know
replace me as a stand-up comic
you'd be surprised how far some of this
stuff is going did you see the movie uh
Deus
no okay no wait a minute or No Ex
Machina yeah I've seen wasn't that an
amazing movie
I was fooled were you fooled by well the
whole thing of who the real person was
versus the virtual
where you you the the woman is the robot
yeah yeah but I was fooled what did you
think I didn't she had me fault oh that
she was real I understand what you're
saying I have a completely different
approach I think there's like a weird
um Freudian edible thing going on in
that movie that you're the child the
child is the robot you fall in love with
the mother to convince them to let you
out and you kill the father on the way
out well yeah but how yeah but those
layers are can be true oh yeah no I'm
not saying I mean just that it can be
done now with that it was so built into
her
programming
that all the little tricks that I
thought oh that's why you couldn't fool
me right right she fooled me let me put
this to you though because you and I
aren't in different that different of uh
professions meaning ramdas had a very
similar comedic style I think it was
very funny he actually did stand up in
the village in a little bit anyway what
I'm saying is when I'm doing a show and
when you're giving a talk I would
imagine you you have a similar feeling I
oh my Mantra is it's not about the words
I believe that chat gbt probably today
you could write into chat GPT you know
that AI write a joke in the style of
Pete Holmes about bananas and how
they're better than Apples and it might
it might do it but I just did a show I
was in Seattle last night went great
wasn't about the words I hear that and I
agree with you yeah they can't they're
not human and they will not be human
that that's what like the idea that it
could write material I'll concede that
today no no part of my ego goes like
only I could write my [__] I'm
saying when what they're actually
experiencing is like average Tire when
you're holding arms but around the tree
yeah it's and what we're experiencing I
get the best seat in the house I'm here
with you people listen to the words but
what they're actually getting is a
feeling of connection yeah and that's
what you're paying for and that's why my
special will never be as good as seeing
me well you know this brings up so much
because on one hand you're absolutely
correct oh it's so funny and Alan Watts
book over there you're really you're
totally back to my generation yeah yeah
it's called Bernie smoke a doobie listen
to Mountain watch records
the uh
even without AI
how tricked we can be like sociopathic
Behavior I mean all kinds of stuff can
can trick us and I mean that's the whole
point of the sociopath who can make you
feel like their feelings are so real yes
that's yeah you don't even need
technology they're like human AIS there
are people and it's a mental disorder
often but it's like they're doing an
impression it's depersonalization you
feel like you're not a member of the
human race this George Santos thing is
really fascinating or really
unfortunately really
anyway yeah sure no I understand what
you're saying criminals and all that
yeah you know what's interesting about
all of this Ai and Instagram and the age
that we're living in do you sometimes
think that there was a spiritual
advantage to the time that you were in
talking about landlines oh my God I say
it all the time who would have thought
we'd be nostalgic for the 70s yeah
um
it was a turbulent time it was a crazy
time no no seven is wasn't really
turbulent and in the more in a way that
we we consume in retrospect it was more
generative than we realized at the time
we thought we were just taking a rest
after the 60s
um but it was like any period of rest
generating the next thing
um
there is no doubt about it I you know I
used to say that I learned most of what
I know on airplanes because I would find
it so fascinating talking to people next
to me on airplanes if somebody doesn't
know you so doesn't have any
preconceived ideas about you everybody's
a little more aware than usual of their
mortality and you really meet all kinds
of people you would never meet under
other circumstances today you get on a
plane and more often than not people
want to close their their drape at their
window they want to close the shade so
that the most magnificent drama of
nature is not available to them for
whatever reason in order to watch a
Grade B movie or get on their tablet or
put on their their earphones immediately
and there's a human being next to them
there's nothing well the entire mystery
of the cosmos is next to them right yes
exactly exactly I remember one man who I
once said hi I'm Marianne he went good
he couldn't even bring himself to say hi
I'm Mark some man he said lin-manuel I'm
like well Miranda
no I totally know what you mean I I
think there's a metaphor there in fact
I'm working on a movie and one of the
symbols is how we're always blocking our
ears we're always putting on we don't
and then we say well where's love I
can't find love the course of Miracle
says you're like people in a very bright
room with your uh fingers in front of
your eyes going it's it's dark in here
yeah I mean we miss out on so much
because we miss the person and that's
why it it concerns me when I see these
little children on tablets right so talk
about quiet and talk about mind
searching and talk about the decision
maker which I you know that term isn't
in the course but Ken talks about the
decision maker Ken wapnick oh yeah the
idea that it's all of this the the two
lessons
yesterday's lesson was my my salvation
comes from me yeah that one forget it
I'm struck with how many times Jesus in
the course is saying the whole thing in
one lesson and my salvation comes from
me was one of those lessons right where
I'll never also love made me like itself
is this is what I mean created me like
itself right and hope created me hopeful
and Faith created me faithful and peace
created me peaceful wholeness created me
holy I have the chills I can't say it
and you know it you know there's a pure
place in you that is all of those things
and this is what I'm putting back to you
and I'm go you know I was just on an
airplane watching a movie yesterday so
I'm not doing it I'm not saying we
shouldn't watch movies
I'm not there all the time but like I
part of the flight I was there part of
the flight I would close my eyes did my
lesson and I was like oh my God I was
right there so forget the 70s Shepherds
with their sheep or you know what I'm
saying like throughout human history we
had more time to spelunk into our inner
reality no we didn't no we didn't have
more time they just have fewer
distractions that's what I mean that's
why you know every religious system or
spiritual system that I've ever read
about emphasizes the power of the
morning if you wake up in the morning
and the first thing you do is you go to
Snapchat or Instagram or your social
media or you download the newspaper You
are downloading the stressful
perspective of the world and it's very
difficult to change later that's why the
Course in Miracles talks about doing the
exercises in the morning all the great
religious systems do if you take the
time and the course of Miracles does say
five minutes spent with the Holy Spirit
in the morning is enough to guarantee he
will be in charge of your thought forms
throughout the day if you do your
exercise in the morning you will have a
different nervous system yeah and if you
instead allow your nervous system to
become wrinkled by all the meaningless
thoughts of the world good luck on not
being depressed by noon right and then
of course uh a regulated capitalism has
come up with an answer for that of
course isn't it I mean you just said a
mouthful but isn't it interesting I
think we sort of get addicted to fear it
becomes like oh it is yes it is yes
absolutely well why do we run to it or
sometimes of course says you want to be
angry if you're angry you want to be
well it's your own mind turned against
you right the mind is so powerful being
literally of the mind of God whatever
thought you think has power
so you were totally at Choice what
thought to think but something you don't
have a choice about is whether or not
your thinking will be powerful so all
thought the courses takes you and those
around you straight to heaven or
straight to hell heaven is not a
condition or a place it's an awareness
of our Oneness hell is not a condition
or a place it's the anxiety that the ego
would have you feel in any moment that
you feel separate from the rest of life
that's how powerful thoughts are and of
course the miracle says there's no such
thing as a neutral thought that goes
back to what we're saying before about
discipline you know you go to the
physical gym you work out because you're
you're honing your physical muscles so
that you can move and be strong with
spiritual exercise you're honing your
attitudinal muscles so you can be
non-reactive and still like the line be
still and know because if I'm not still
I can't know only in Stillness can I get
clarity right so it's it's very parallel
to the physical world and the physical
world there's gravity and as I grow
older if I'm not countering gravity
accumulated weight-bearing Etc my
muscles headed down emotional gravity
psychological gravity if I'm not
repeating accumulated
repetitions of high-minded thoughts I'm
being pulled down by cynicism I'm being
pulled down by negativity I'm being
pulled down by victim Consciousness I'm
being pulled down by anger I'm being
pulled down that that's what emotional
and psychological and spiritual gravity
is so we do spiritual exercise much like
we do physical exercise to hone our
musculature you have an emotional body
just like you have a physical body and
you can have the healthiest physical
body in the world but if you go into a
meeting a business meeting or any person
any relationship and you bring with you
your negativity your cynicism your
nihilism your control people are going I
don't want that
um
it's interesting going back tying what
the lesson was into what you just said
uh Salvation comes from me it's
interesting my my choice of thinking
right and every moment the course of
Miracle says you're making that choice
you make it consciously or you make it
unconsciously but every moment we're
making a choice but and that's power so
starting the day remind remembering that
what you're thinking and your mind State
and what you're being drawn to and what
you're listening to inside right so when
you replace it with someone else's
worldview whether it be ads for things
to buy right that's another thing it's
isn't that salvation I'll admit that
I've when I was a young man I'd order an
iPad and I remember vividly going I
can't die that iPad is coming like like
the iPad was gonna save me and so that
doesn't work and you outgrew that and
yes I did outgrow that but also the ego
you know says I just saw my name on a
marquee last night and I took a moment
to go like this isn't it this won't say
well good good for you Peter virtue
sibling but I'm just saying like isn't
that the point like we think if we're
famous we think if we're rich we think
you know I talked to a friend of mine
the other day and he was his book and
you know it's a big major bestseller and
he said no I'm identifying it with it
too much I said oh give me a break give
your chance you can celebrate for a
couple days you know we don't want to
spiritually bypass it
also well that would even be bypassing
something negative is usually when you
think of spiritual bypassing let's not
bypass something positive there is such
thing as righteous Commerce there is
such thing as righteous uh celebration
it's when you take it Beyond any level
of appropriate uh perspective that
there's a problem but I think it's cool
the first time you see your name on a
marquee you go cool sure this would have
been the 500 so I'm starting to get over
it
I don't take it too far well it's
interesting it's it's what are we
talking about when we talk about
salvation like well the only thing to be
safe from is your own insane thinking
right that's the course of Miracles the
only thing to be saved from is the
thought system of fear and separation
that dominates this world yeah I I
absolutely love that so if my name on
the Marquee leads to the thought will I
be here next year or will the show sell
out that's not helpful if I go I did a
show I did a good job but I can't it's
like my Angela said you can't pick it up
you can't lay it down right I can't live
and die by whether or not the show went
well right well the ego will always take
you to whatever thought if you're
successful the ego once says yeah but
you might not be successful tomorrow the
ego will take whatever the circumstance
is and interpret it in such a way is to
make you feel bad right because your
pain is the ego's peak experience and
you know and Freud said yeah Freud said
that that intelligence will be used in
the service of the Neurosis so the ego
will just say whatever it is to make you
unable to just enjoy the moment says
then you worry about losing the house
and I see it well exactly the thing is
if the course of Miracle says that the
Holy Spirit your salvation lies in a
different sense of purpose so your
different sense of purpose is
um I am here uh at this theater to do a
comedy show and my hope is that my
talents and my expertise will be used in
such a way to uplift people and give
them some happiness while they're here
so the more you are proactively in the
light about it the darkness cannot enter
Because and I see this in my career a
lot
um
if I there are people who say wonderful
things about me and there are people who
say horrible things about me well if you
become attached to one you just there's
a certain level of detachment
because one of the things I've seen in
my life people who know me they know me
this is not that she's not that
so if you if you try to stay with a
positive I'm only with A Course in
Miracles trains it's about is I'm only
here to be helpful I'm only here
hopefully to serve then yeah you're
excited if your name's on the Marquee
and the theater's sold out but you're
also if you're at a dip in your career
and the theater is not sold out you also
realize well if there are five people
who hear me well one person who hurts me
hears me and they were served
then my piece lies there that's the
that's the spaciousness that's also
recognizing that the person next to you
on the airplane is the entire universe
wrapped in a different package is that
same sort of Stillness that five people
in a not sold out theater is still
precious does that make sense yeah I had
a a Drama teacher when I was in high
school
and there are quite a few
famous actors who were taught by this
drama teacher
um Brent Spiner the Quade Brothers
um Tommy schlami a lot of people who
became kind of big in Hollywood
I was the only one in that little group
who didn't go into theater
but the training that we got from Mr
Pickett has informed me in my work as
much as them I believe because I'm in
front of an audience et cetera and one
of the things that Mr Pickett used to
say to us is
if one person is in the audience
if one person is in the audience you do
your best for them and I remember
feeling early in my career
um
when I used to many decades ago I lived
in New York and I used to go hear
Cabaret singers and sometimes there'd be
somebody who I didn't think was that
great but the whole room was just going
nuts over them other times when I think
somebody was so wonderful and
everybody's talking and laughing and
eating and I'm thinking they don't even
realize who's here and I said to myself
and then this became operative for me in
my career
I said if I'm ever on stage
I want to imagine myself on the back row
would I be impressed yeah would I be
impressed and you start
you stop playing for an audience you
play for the value of the the quality of
the joke the value of the word that you
just wrote the value of Truth telling to
whatever in whatever way you might and
other people's opinion becomes less
important if they're happy with you
that's great but you know sometimes when
people are unhappy with something you
said sometimes it's because you said the
wrong thing sometimes it's because you
said the right thing you
so we have to start developing this
concept of like living for the ages
living for something higher than just
somebody's immediate opinion and if
you're only
doing it for somebody's immediate
liking of you that's the sales mentality
right that has trapped us all in a
pretty dark place as opposed to
something richer and longer lasting
absolutely and meaningful there's a part
in the course where it says this world
does not have deep enough roots to
sustain you because like you said and
this town is filled with it
and you know we've all had our moments
there I mean I've I've
been through a lot in my life but
a lot that this society says if only
you'll have the house
if only you have the car if only you
have the relationship if only you have
and a lot of people who have gotten a
lot of the things I thought would make
them so happy and
felt on some deeper level oh yeah
there's got to be more than this we just
talked about we watched a video online
of Elon Musk getting a million dollar
car and I was like you can almost see it
in his eyes like a little I'm not saying
he's a little baby I'm just saying in
him a deep baby that's going it's not
working the million dollar car is here
well clear wheels and a steering wheel I
mean clearly look how much he's posting
on Twitter just trying like a kid who
wants somebody to like him or something
yeah that never I or it hasn't gone away
well we're living in an age where we're
seeing the bear truth about
billionaires in a way that I think
needed to happen but it doesn't work I
wouldn't say that it's not for me to say
it doesn't work but we live in a society
that made the businessman God you know
we have the soulless economic system
that exalted the businessman
um if you're a successful businessman
and we have seen
um
some things in the last few years I
think we saw it a lot through covet
um
I think I myself thought
during the worst ravages of covet that
there would be people whether they were
people who manufactured uh equipment uh
whether it was people who manufactured
vaccines were it whether it was people
who could have afforded to say you know
during this period of time we're just
going to throw in however many hundreds
of millions to make sure that they that
the shelves are not empty in any uh you
know a food pantry in the United States
you really saw during covet how the
system works in such a way that it's
really okay if people die
that we will not allow anything to
impinge on an economic bottom line a
short-term profit for huge corporate
entities
um I think people get that now I don't
think you have to be really obtuse now
to not recognize that the system does
not love you right the system does not
love you and the system does not care
about you and it's lying to you well
yeah because they're trying to sell you
it it's it's
demonic and un you know a system that
has no ethics to it so we've we've we've
developed a society where we still at
least in name value personal ethics but
we bought into this lie that capitalism
doesn't have to have ethics when in fact
um Adam Smith you know primary
articulator of free market capitalism
said it cannot exist without outside an
ethical context
uh you have the CEO of modernism the
other day saying they're going to make
the covid vaccine they're going to go up
in price 400 times 400 percent and he
said well the market will stand it
right the market it's all about the
market right right which is a concept
and we've seen that corporations and
markets are sociopaths right I mean well
on federal markets I do think there's
such a thing as rights as profit don't
get me wrong
um there is such a thing as a healthy
righteous appropriate exchange of energy
that involves money I believe that like
I said if the publisher because I come
from a a career where I've seen that it
can be a gentleman's business where
everyone wins nobody's losing from
you're doing a podcast do you know what
I'm saying that there is such a thing as
righteous Commerce no I hear you I hear
you but there's also an unrighteous
Congress and and unrighteous when you
have these huge corporate behemoths
um and we we all know what that is is
doing to people's lives and again it
goes down to this weird like the phones
listening or the designed opsolescence
or whatever it is I feel like in
politics there there's almost an
understanding that we're being lied to
or it's not going to work but we'll
we'll trade it for the feeling that
maybe something's like there's a fervor
of like maybe we're gonna do it maybe
we're going to make America great and no
matter what happens you just kind of we
like people are just going along with it
I don't know I mean we're not a monolith
we've got we're 360 million people so I
don't presume to know what everybody's
thinking I do know this I worry about
the young I worry about people who don't
remember when it wasn't this way and I'm
particularly worried about
um teenagers and children whose
prefrontal cortex hasn't even been
formed yet so
um you and I are old enough to figure
some of this out for ourselves you and I
are old enough to say I just spent an
hour scrolling through
Instagram for What freaking reason I
learned nothing it's stupid I watch but
what is this I'm just addicted put down
the phone we're old enough doesn't love
you it doesn't it doesn't yeah right and
and so you and I are old enough to
figure some of that out and then I think
a lot of people are figuring and I don't
think everybody's just going along I
think people these days are realizing
the addictive nature of some of this how
unfair to capitalism what it's done I I
think actually we're living in a very
powerful moment of Awakening actually I
think but younger people who are being
trained into it from such an early age
that's where I think
there's a lot to worry about I mean
there are so many aspects of that of
what young people are going through now
even like with the school shootings you
think we have a mental health crisis now
we are now raising an entire generation
of children going to school every day
hoping they won't get shot yeah
that's that's the definition and knowing
that basically we're not doing anything
about it so good luck kids right right
that's the most forget about what we
learned in kova that it's okay that
people are dying it still seems okay
it's obviously not but that seems to be
the message like we're not going to do
anything about it yeah absolute absolute
Insanity
um let's talk a little bit
we were talking before this about
happiness
what I'm interested you know it's
interesting when we were setting up this
interview I was
under the misconception that you were
like
a person that was like manifest things
get things get what you want get the
hell I know that's silly I did my
research between then and now but I'd
love to hear you speak about what brings
happiness and and you know what might be
a nice place to start in A Course in
Miracles what is the miracle because so
many people they go of Course in
Miracles oh I'll read this book it's a
book of spells and I will um get a
beautiful partner and I'll get millions
of dollars because those are Miracles
that's what we think Miracles are so I
think those answers are tied right what
is the miracle and what has happened
it's the difference in course in Miracle
storms it's the difference between Magic
and miracles so magic is that sort of
manifestation thing like you're
basically using goddess or Aaron boy I'd
like an apartment in Santa Monica at the
beach and I'd like this these numbers on
the money that I make and I'd like a
person who looks and does that uh and
you're basically trying to use Universal
principle to get what you want that's
not the spiritual Mountaintop
the spiritual Mountaintop is hear my
hands hear my feet
is my brain here's my tongue with which
I can speak
a spirit of Love used me
it's the opposite almost right it is the
opposite
um there's there's a potential arrogance
of manifesting is that you know what you
need well it's not just an arrogance
it's you don't know what's going to
happen tomorrow I mean that's the whole
thing in the course is that the holy
spirit is a part of your mind that's not
going to know that knows what's going to
happen tomorrow so you're trying to
decide should I go to Boston or should I
move to Atlanta so you put down on a
piece of paper what are the you know
what are the good things about moving to
Boston what is the downside of moving to
Boston what is the good thing about
moving to Atlanta what is the downside
of moving to Atlanta but you that's the
part of your mind that doesn't know
what's going to happen six months from
now so sometimes you look at the piece
of paper and
it it you know the sort of logical
conclusion is I should move to Atlanta
but everything in youth has moved to
Boston moved to Boston and we don't know
that you listen to that voice and then
six months later something happens you
go oh no I should have gone to Boston so
when you meditate you know in both
Judaism and Christianity there's this uh
concept of the small still Voice Within
when we were talking before about
meditating be still a no you become a
finely tuned intuitional instrument you
listen to people you listen to what the
doctor says you listen to what the
lawyer says you listen what the account
says you listen to what the agent says
you listen to what your friends say
but the ultimate what is your god sign
they're gonna consult with you about
your best options
and when you become prayerful about
something you're going to hear from a
part of the brain that knows things that
you don't know knows people you're going
to meet knows how your talents and
abilities would best fit in there's that
wonderful line of Nietzsche uh the the
music
what is it the dancer seems insane to
those who cannot hear the music yes yes
well if time is an illusion and it's
already happened is there a part of you
that literally does well I've been
thinking about that that's so
interesting that you say that because oh
here I am in your life uh yeah really
you showed up it manifests
um yeah I have actually been thinking
about that is it actually a future
memory because the Course in Miracles
does say everything's already happened
and time is an illusion yeah well even
Einstein said Einstein said time and
space or illusions of Consciousness
albeit insistent persistent ones
consistent ones that's right yeah yeah
the only time the ideas in the course is
that the only time that's real is
eternity and the only place where
eternity intersects uh linear time is in
the present the past is only in your
mind the future is only in your mind so
the ego always wants us thinking about
the past or the future in order to avoid
the present because the present is where
the miracle is which is that shift from
Fear To Love and past is guilt and
future is fear right yeah but it's not
love right right so now one of the
lessons in the course is uh the past is
over it can touch me not and I place the
future in the hands of God
I I love that very much it's also one of
the things that seems to be I'd love to
just get your expertise on this
the course also thinks that if there is
a perfect Oneness God's perfect Oneness
like heaven then we're already there
have you ever meditated on that I I
enjoyed the idea that is the separation
never happened the atonement is already
it's all a hallucination the noted in
Heaven song was missed so you and I are
in heaven right now we're just kind of
having a strange dream
well but the course of Miracles talks
about the highest level of thinking of
which the ego is capable so I I can get
that this is heaven I mean this I am at
a point in my life when I get there
isn't anything else right now I Marianne
I know we're supposed to be really where
you're supposed to be sitting with this
guy named Pete who's this comedian who
does the podcast how do you know because
you are right you are there isn't
anything else right there isn't anything
else so it's all about how do you
inhabit the space of where you are
Heaven being the awareness of Oneness
right and salvation comes from me so you
go to I go to me for that I made a
blessing you are I'm not I'm either
showing up to the best of my ability or
not but my the value of this to me will
not be based on you the value of me will
be based on whether I show up and if I
show up it's going to make you want to
show up more right but that's on the
level of form isn't there also something
going on that's not on the level but
none of that that I just said is the
level of form my showing up in the
situation is really not about it's an
energy you're feeling for me yes do you
know what I'm going to say I can't
replace this yes well you know what I
mean
what's going on here is not just form
form the tongue is being used but
there's a look in our eyes or or there's
a sense that yes I'm really engaged in
this conversation it's really not about
form um
I guess you've got you helped me realize
that I think that there's something that
has nothing to do with this that's going
on behind this no the course says the
courses Beyond this world there is a
world I want but it's the same world
transformed by sense of purpose you
extend your perception beyond what your
physical senses perceive to what your
heart knows to be true but it's not
somewhere else thinking it somewhere
else is no different than thinking it's
after we die no it's right here
but it's just that there's no place
where you stop and I start but right now
we're in this Mortal experience and this
is cool too right this is interesting
yes absolutely
pardon the interruption weirdos this
time of year everyone's talking about
making big changes which is all well and
good but you know most of the time
pretty unrealistic I've actually found
that the smallest changes to your
routine can actually make the biggest
impact in the same way you don't have to
break the bank to make a big deal
purchase even the smallest things can be
part of a big change if it's something
you use every day like my raycons my
incredible raycon earbuds raycon is
premium audio at the perfect price point
so you can build great habits without
breaking the bank they're perfect for
the gym they stay in place they don't
short circuit when you get a little
sweaty they last an incredible amount of
time they keep my energy up and keep my
gym routine let's just say oh let's make
it 10 minutes longer all right the music
is carrying me through whether you're
looking for a pair of everyday earbuds
or low latency gaming earphones or
headphones or speaker with a battery
that will last all night at your next
party raycon has got you covered and yep
raycon started at half the price half
the price of other premium audio Brands
so you don't have to choose between
products you can get one of each a pair
and a spare and still pay less than you
would with some of the other guys get
the headphones get another pair of
headphones let's be honest it's nice to
have a travel set it's nice to have one
that's your everyday go around in your
pocket ones that's what I do even if you
know you'll love your raycons as much as
I do raycon wants to make you sure make
sure you feel great about your purchase
they offer buy now pay later options
they even provide every purchase with a
free return
guarantee so you can have uh three
customizable sound profiles earbud tap
functions noise isolation awareness mode
custom gel tips for the perfect most
comfortable in-ear fit Crystal Clear
call Quality Water and sweat resistance
and 8 or 11 hours of Play Time depending
on the everyday earbuds or the speaker
the earbuds is eight the speaker is 11.
so ready to buy something small with a
big impact go to buy raycon.com weirdo
today to get 15 off your raycon order
that's by raycon.com weirdo to score 15
off by raycon.com
weirdo alright everybody let's get back
to Marianne Williamson
it's a little dumpier than me I think
you could do the won't start or
something but well the camera's only
poisonous so they can't see the
nightmare that you are beholding I do
think it's interesting though the okay
so what we're talking about is is
getting into this a little more this
isn't quite right but cleanly and one of
the things that I told you is so metal
and so acid like burning about the
chorus is it's like let's get real you
are filled with judgment and and hate
and grievance and everything is wrong I
I got a flat tire last night and I was
just like how could there be a pothole
on a major road that that I just I just
ran over at flat tire and how could
roadside service be closed on a Sunday
night just closed couldn't do anything
left the car in the parking lot it was a
nightmare so you get really excited
about being upset but then the grievance
getting rid of these Grievances and and
forgiving can we talk a little bit about
well the course of Miracle says there is
a highly individualized curriculum for
every person
well the course would say that was the
perfect lesson for you in that moment
because every every situation both
invites us to be better and challenges
us to go back into our ego default so
the ego default is God damn why why
they're pothole in the major
is falling apart and they don't even
have a
blah uh
more interesting I said develop I was
like don't they pay their taxes in Santa
Barbara like but it's the rain I
realized today that the rain is making
the point okay so the course would say
that you would go oh this is perfect
this is perfect for me to see my upset
that's right about even little things
okay perfect Universe if it's the
universe if you're so perfect fix this
so the course of Miracle says only
infinite patience produces immediate
results so say okay so my car is not
available what's the the and then you
are able to settle into that moment
without the craziness now I don't say
that like I can do that 24 7. but I'm at
a point where I would know oh this is an
interesting
um challenge this happened to uh you're
not quite Miss uh calm and Serene now
are you missing right that's right well
there is a humility to it oh it totally
makes us it keeps us humble to go wow I
became a [__] very quickly when that
was right right well to quote our hat
over there Richard Royce is the first
forgiveness in in is to reality you have
to forgive reality and I I find that
very valuable it's another way of saying
the great way is easy for those who have
no preferences uh you go like oh sure I
have a flat tire but you know I make my
bed in the depths and you're there I
make my bed in the heavens you're there
I have a flat tire and you were there
nothing there is no spot where God is
not that's right and nothing real change
something literally in in the Manifest
World also you don't know so you're
gonna have uh at some point the AAA
driver is going to come
and how are you going to play that and
what what possible gift is there going
to be from your waiting you know you
don't know we did we already somebody
pulled over and offered to help yeah
which was very sweet oh the car that I
drive doesn't have a spare tire in it so
that was the problem so I was like great
this guy so look at all the richness of
that which was learned and so forth
totally absolutely I do want to talk a
little bit about
the way that course the the course looks
at forgiveness because
and intellectual forgiveness where I
even acknowledge oh oh Marianne let's
say you ran into my car when you parked
which you didn't but you did that I I
was always raised with like an
intellectual forgiveness which is it's
okay I've done things like that maybe
she's having a bad like I rationalize
why it's okay to forgive you as opposed
to just like the course says I'm
forgiving my sister for doing something
she didn't even do like it didn't even
really so the course of Miracles talks
the traditional forgiveness is you were
a jerk just now but I'm very spiritual
yeah so I will deign to forgive you so
the chorus points out that that's
judgment yes that's called forgiveness
to destroy so what the course of Miracle
says is let's say you were unloving to
me let's say you were rude to me you
were mean to me
um the course says if you were rude to
me if you were mean to me
then in that something happened there
was something about my behavior
something about the situation triggered
some place in you where you don't know
how to be loving and get your needs met
okay so in that moment it's like wires
got crossed in your brain you fell
asleep to who you are
Only Love is Real
so if you behaved unlovingly the course
of Miracle says you're in a
hallucination you've fallen asleep to
who you are now I have a choice whether
or not to go to sleep with you in that
if I then base my perception of you on
that mean look in your face and those
mean words then I am falling asleep into
the dream with you my job the primary
work of responsibility of The Miracle
Worker it says is to accept the
atonement for himself so I can choose to
remain awake to extend my perception
beyond what your physical my physical
senses just saw to know dear God I know
he's a loving person I'm willing to see
this differently that's the word in the
course it's a big deal willingness
willingness your good intentions are not
enough it says your willingness is
everything dear God I'm willing to know
he's a very nice man and I I am willing
to see this difference if I'm not a nice
man because well you might want to be a
nice man but you're still an innocent
Soul so I am willing to see this
differently and I'm willing to and
interpret all Behavior as either love or
a call for love okay that's when it gets
really interesting because at that point
my main responsibility is to find that
sweet neutral spot Within Myself where I
realize you're an innocent child of God
then and only then will I know whether
I'm supposed to take the [__] or leave
the room
right so then once I'm in that sweet
spot
I'll know first of all it might be an
Awakening for you because subconsciously
you'll feel my blessing and I might
actually see you begin to change which
is really amazing when that happens or
it might be something where it continues
in such a way and the spirit in me with
all love knows I I'm not supposed to
stay in this room for this it would not
serve him for him to think I'd be
available for this and it would not and
it would be respect for myself to leave
but even then it would be a stylish a
kind a you know I think I'm going to
leave her now
a high quality no like a rich because
Love sometimes says no but until I get
to that point of forgiveness for you I
don't have the clarity um
the one of the lines that I love is God
Is the Love In which I forgive and God
Is the Love In which I think God is the
mind which I mean that that whole series
there God is not because it's not your
human mind and it takes you to some
other place yeah yeah I guess what I'm
saying is sometimes Pete can't forgive
sometimes it's too hard but Pete can be
willing to surrender it into the love
well for those who buy into the Jesus
part of the course you know the course
is not about
you know he says you do not have to
believe in me but if you do there's that
much more the idea of the Savior you
were talking about salvation before
it says there would be no savior if
there were no need for one so the idea
on the course is okay maybe Pete was a
little mean to me it's not a huge deal
but let's say me Pete was
let's make this not Pete let's say
somebody did something really horrible
to me and it is more than I can forgive
by myself he says in the course my mind
joined with your mind can shine away the
ego right that's when you say I I I need
help here this is this is a bigger
trigger this is not a matter of a friend
you're saying oh lighten up I need some
real help here and amazing things do
happen because even though the course is
very hardcore non-dual it speaks in
dualistic language and says take my hand
I'll walk you through this I'll I'll
dissolve like
like the Salvation comes from me it's
powerful for me when I thought it's me
and it's my mind which means it's not
even the Course in Miracles I I picture
all my teachers I picture around us it's
very interesting I picture Jesus I
picture my concept of God and I go it's
it's it's in here it's that that's the
concept of the Holy Spirit the internal
teacher the internal teacher the memory
of perfect Oneness right and he says um
if you're confused and you're having
trouble with any of this imagine
yourself as a small child put out your
hand and I am an elder brother I will
take your hand and then he says this is
no Idol fantasy that's right I just did
that one that's the one where it's the
circle of light and you have to move the
clouds aside and what I think and the
clouds you just it's just hot air that's
right that's right you you think that oh
it's a bank of clouds you just move
right through it it's just a just hot
air that's all your ego is yes can I
compliment you and say I thought you
were beautiful and wonderful meaning
your behavior is beautiful I mean in the
the uh in the debates I think we've done
politically and I got very excited for
you thank you the one question I was
like as a course person I was almost
projecting into the future where it was
maybe if you run again I it's not that I
worry I go what if someone were to say
you know in a fiercely non-dual way
doesn't God not know about this world if
God is perfect Oneness acknowledging
this reality would be making the
illusion real yeah and of course it's
very clear about bringing the darkness
to the light don't drag the light into
the darkness I'm just wondering that's
right he's does the the teacher the
teachers of God are sent into the
darkness of the world that would be like
a doctor saying do that gash on your
hand that's toxic that's gross let's
look at your knee you you have to look
at the wounds the course in Miracle says
look at the crucifixion but do not dwell
on it there are a lot of people today
who want to skip the crucifixion and go
right to the resurrection this kind of
Kumbaya thing which is not Transcendence
it's denial or Jews who want to go right
to the delivery to the promised land but
yeah but there was that slavery in Egypt
thing happened first uh Buddha became
enlightened after he left his father's
house and saw human suffering for the
first time there's no serious spiritual
path including the course that gives
anyone a pass around on a drug using the
suffering of other sentient beings so
the course of Miracles does say that the
plan for the teachers of God which means
anyone who chooses to be one all
religions and no religion are people
just say use me and you were sent to
whatever area of Darkness like you said
you have to bring the darkness to the
light
um and then and then it comes up and you
are to be the alternative to leave
politics out of that seems kind of
ridiculous to me uh Gandhi said is not
politics a part of Dharma too Gandhi
also said anyone who doesn't uh think
religion has anything to do with
politics doesn't understand religion and
he also said politics should be sacred
politics is simply our collective
decision making
so you know what I feel if if you if
we're a bunch of Americans just talking
anybody in this room we go as deep and
get as real as anybody does anywhere in
the world
but in our public conversation we keep
to a level of superficiality
um grandiosity denial that's um kind of
horrifying a lot of people disrespect us
for it but it's particularly dangerous
right now when politics should be and
for the same this happens for the same
reason that you and I talked about
earlier there are forces whose power is
maintained and perpetuated by you and me
acting like a bunch of seventh graders
when it comes to political issues we're
talking about the survivability of the
planet here we're talking about the
survivability of our grandchildren we're
talking about suffering of millions and
millions of people
um we don't get to take a pass on this
and and call it um
uh oh it's it's an illusion anyway
um the course in Miracle says it's an
illusion forgiveness is an illusion but
there are illusions that lead you beyond
the illusion where to go to the highest
level of thinking of which the ego is
capable so I think people who have an
understanding of spiritual and
psychological issues are the last people
who should be sitting out the Great
I mean who have an understanding of of
personal growth and personal change are
the last people who should be sitting
out the political and economic issues
because if you have an idea what changes
one person you're the one who has an
idea what would change a system and what
would change a country
that's I I completely agree with all of
that it in the debate situation though
if somebody said like when I got my flat
tire last night I was like this is
interesting this is the first
um situational like physical oh this is
a situation where people ask God for
help right classic and I was like that's
interesting because I've been studying
the course for seven well longer than 70
days but I've been doing the workbook
for 70 days I was like my interpretation
seems to be that God doesn't know about
this world this is there is perfect one
of course what's that God doesn't but
the Holy Spirit does yes okay let's go
with that yeah well God it's not
happening like you said it's only
happening in hallucination right in my
eyes but the moment but God is the
answer to every problem the moment the
problem occurred so as soon as this
hallucination was born this thought of
Separation which then manifests with the
body and all the physical
evidence of Separation in that moment
God placed within our minds and once God
places it there it's an eternal creation
called in the course and another
christ-centered philosophy the holy
spirit in the Urantia book it's called
The Thought adjuster it's Shekinah all
the great religious systems have the
word for it and it it's like sit it
stands on the fence it sees you in your
reality which is how God knows you and
also sees you within the stream and has
been authorized by God to enter into the
dream with you
[Music]
and help you transform the dream
and remember when Helen asked for Helen
checkman who described the course she
asked for help and Jesus said I forget
where this is in the text but he says
don't ask for help with this problem ask
for help changing your mind well you're
probably your greatest power to change
the world is to change your mind about
the world for instance if I have a flat
tire
um
I'm not I'm not an advanced enough
student of these things that I would not
get crazy around it
but I'm Advanced enough that I would say
this isn't about the flat tire it's
about how crazy you felt right now this
is about the fact that you you think you
know that this is so insane everything
can work out you can call the people who
you're supposed to meet for lunch
someone can come you go to the place of
peace first
and once again just the willingness to
say dear God I just give this to you I I
I just give this to you right I heard
again I I don't know how you how do you
feel about Ken wapnick are you do you
enjoy him
I knew Ken oh you did um Ken WAP Nick
for those listening it was one of the
friends of Helen and he was one of the
early teachers of it and somebody I've
listened to quite a bit and I I heard
him say that it's like we're watching a
puppet show and we keep asking God to
intervene with the happenings in the
puppet show yeah that's right or it's
like watching a movie and thinking that
you can uh change the plot by
manipulating the screen right it's all
in your mind so the holy spirit will not
the course of Miracle says the law of
cause and effect was designed for your
protection God once God has created law
he himself will not violate it and so
you can't hold to your thoughts that
created a negative effect and ask God to
change the effect
to say God save me in this situation
means save me from my thinking that is
producing that effect right right right
right the issue in life is not what just
happened but who do I choose to be in
the space of what happened and what's
interesting about a flat tire and I'd
love to obviously everything I say I'm
just saying to get your thoughts on it
it's like it is the pain of Separation
it is sort of the pain of guilt meaning
something broke and I feel deep down in
my mind in like my insane mind that I
broke I broke away from God and I'm
guilty for that are you dragging with me
so when something breaks in this world
it's almost like I I want it to be wrong
I want the road to be wrong I want the
car to be wrong I don't want to be wrong
the universe works like a GPS the moment
a wrong turn is taken the GPS
immediately recalibrates
your your path so God is the answer to
every problem the moment a problem
occurs the moment the the problem
occurred
it's already it's already
factored into the the Machinery of it
all that this is going to be handled
you're getting all crazy about it it's
going to make it more difficult get
peaceful about it
get calm get quiet oh I have AAA I know
who to call
get peaceful and you'll know exactly
what to do and this will have been a
great lesson in handling the issues of
life because they do occur
[Music]
it's interesting I keep I keep what I
keep getting from the course is like it
they're going to occur they're always
going to occur the world is always going
to be crazy the answer isn't fixing the
world well but wait a minute because
theoretically if you get to the point
where you don't need that lesson
you you might not have to you might go
around that pothole
but I'd still be a beautiful painting
that's fading though and cracking like
this is a place where starved and
thirsty in our lifetime all the problems
will not be over
um the issue is
will you be here to help heal them
and also I think for myself there's also
something about
first of all I found 90 of the time in
my life
the best advice I can give myself is get
over yourself
this is so inconsequential to the larger
things that are happening in this world
look at what's happening in Iran look at
what's happening in Afghanistan look at
what's happening get over yourself and
it does help you have a greater uh
willingness
to be a person who can handle who can
sweat don't sweat the small stuff
and it's awesome it's all spoiled no but
there's big stuff and if I'm sweating
the small stuff I'm not showing up for
this isn't that a hierarchy of Illusions
isn't that yeah that is a hierarchy of
Illusions but there is a hard rock
Evolution the Course in Miracles talks
about the course is an illusion that
leads Beyond illusion I mean there's a
level of which you and me being here is
an illusion but that doesn't mean it
doesn't matter
because your love is here that's not
what my physical senses see your desire
to do something with your life that
matters is here so it's not like there's
no reality here my desire to show up for
life in a way that's meaningful is here
so to say the illusion is the couch and
the body but what we're really trying to
be to increase our value is real isn't
God created me helpful
right so it's not like God's not here
it's just that the god that's here is
not what we perceive with our physical
senses but reality is here
Ultimate Reality is here it's just
beyond the screen of of of the the
physical that we see but we can feel it
there isn't anything more than that
human beings and get in touch with that
and you get in touch with it by blessing
the other and and just trying to be your
best in a situation what are some of
those mantras you carry with you because
you see me well I I'm like you I you
know to me it's about it's about
um uh it's about that Course in Miracles
lesson in the morning uh a meaningless
world and gender sphere is is mine oh
that's the one that puts me back to
sleep when I wake up at 3am I go of
course you're afraid right because you
were registering all this is real yeah
so I I have a different nervous system
on a day when I did my exercise in the
morning there's no doubt about it I
completely agree with you yeah I I try
not to make it a ritual or like a like
an idol or something but I do love it
and if I miss it yeah what's wrong yeah
today how many times have you gone
through the workbook do you just
practice well I started reading the
course of Miracles when I was in my
mid-20s then I'm 70 now wow so that's
incredible by the way yeah
if but you're you're kind of killing it
yeah you're doing a great job before me
yeah exactly but you've gone through it
because I'm just curious as a student
I'm like oh I I feel like when I do this
I'm going to want to do it again
this is your first time yeah it's not
like you graduate into enlightened
Mastery you know after doing it once but
you you certainly sound like someone
who's really uh you know under
understanding the principles there's no
doubt about it but it's like going to
the gym you never get to the point where
you don't have to go anymore yeah you
never get to say okay well I love how I
look now I don't have to do it anymore I
mean it's maintenance it's you know yeah
that's that's wonderful I it's
interesting sometimes I read the course
and it sounds like you'll get to a place
and the universe will disappear have you
ever well technically that's what would
happen the course of Miracle says if you
really get this there's no need to be
here any longer but anytime somebody
said to me man I'm really worried about
this because the course says if I really
learn all this there's no need for me to
be here anymore and you'll vanish and
I've always thought don't worry I'm not
that close uh sometimes I think about
myself you know you really should be
more advanced by now but
I I understand the ways that I am and I
understand the ways that I'm not and
yeah um but you know that feeling I mean
I'm sure you've had deep meditation
where you're like it's almost like the
more things change the more they stay
the same here I am I grew up
fundamentalist Christian and now I'm
like am I going to be Rapture it's not
even Rapture are we all going to be
raptured is the whole thing gonna pop
but then I'm like what do we do with
stories of the historical Jesus or other
enlightened people whoever it might be
um you know people are waking up and
staying here it seems
I don't understand what the question is
I'm saying if I wake up we all wake up
we wake you know when I was a child we
had these little outer pearl necklaces
and there was a holiday or you get
another girl get another Pro my mom
tried to do that so the course of
Miracles talks about the Holy instant
in some instance we do you have children
yeah four-year-old so a four-year-old
Daniel she's great
so the moment you first held her
you knew Bliss yeah first when you first
fell in love with your wife you knew
plus we've all had those moments
and then it's about those moments of
peace
getting to the point where they become
more the exception than the role
and you get to a place or at least the
goal is to get to a place where it
doesn't have to be the utter
magnificence of holding my child for the
first time or falling in love for the
first time
if there can be just a deep peace with
what is as you develop you know you were
talking before about my salvation comes
from me you develop a kind of Namaste
their Consciousness so if you go into a
room and you go into let's say a crowded
place I I noticed this with airports all
the time because I'm in airports a lot
okay and I realized you can look around
and just say silently the love in me
salutes the love in you the love in me
salutes the love in you you can either
put these blinders on all these people
have to get to the plane or you can go
I can bless that person and I can bless
that person and I can bless that person
I can bless that person and it's going
to change the tenor of my experience
that's beautiful as somebody who spent
four hours in the Seattle Airport
yesterday yeah I totally know what you
mean yeah and you start wondering like
then you start looking at people
differently I wonder where they came
from I wonder where they're going I
wonder what they're going through can
you sing those pearls start to string
together so it's almost like the
rehearsals the union I felt when I felt
my held my daughter or fell in love with
my wife or or get into a nice flow with
you these are little wake-up reminders
and then you can get to a place where
you extend that experience well
they're the they're the holy instance um
but only your ego would say well if I do
this enough I'll get no this is it right
right this is it and I think Early
Childhood particularly
um four-year-old I mean that's my
favorite that's totally my favorite I
could rent a four-year-old every year
yeah something's over at five you know
you you and your wife are you are you no
no okay you and your wife are
the everything once she goes to school
it's you'll stop being everything you'll
be the main thing for a lot longer to
miss the magic of Early Childhood I
think is one of the saddest
the magic of it
no I agree it's the magic of a
four-year-old so that's what I think
sometimes we miss when we're young we
don't get this is it you know every
woman you get older and you you look at
pictures of when you were young and I've
talked to so many women like that you
look at a picture of yourself when you
were 30 and you go
I thought that was inadequate I mean we
we live you you live your life the ego
going
what's going to happen in the future
will I get there even spiritually well I
got to a moment now how about just this
moment right this is it no you're right
on it's beautiful I'm not surprised but
there is a I I suppose it's coming from
an ego level where I'm like
the idea that this is all our Collective
dream there's only one mind having this
dream so the idea and we we agreed that
there are parts of the course that seem
to imply that this could be over in an
instant I'm pretty sure that's that's a
quote it's this could be over if like
you you could walk into the light so
easily why do you keep playing in the
shadows so it's this idea that like
Enlightenment would be Enlightenment for
everybody I guess and we're just playing
in different levels I suppose but the
idea that there are enlightened Masters
what are we doing here if anybody woke
up wouldn't we have all woken up well
what the course of Miracle says is
because there are those who have woken
up the option is available to us they're
here to show us the way have you had
experience do you know anybody that you
feel like was enlightened or ever
studied you're saying that you say that
you know what the one person I know who
I feel in his presence like he's there
Eckert oh Eckhart
I do feel that way around Ecker time
yeah that's really nice to hear because
I've gone I saw him and Ryan back at the
Omega Institute and it was really
special yeah and meaningful yeah he's so
sweet and it's there's a page in be here
now that is really meaningful to me it's
like the power of knowing that other
people it happened for other people can
really give you this this hope and so if
you were like yeah but we already had
Jesus and Buddha and Moses I mean what I
mean I didn't see any of them in
Rhinebeck you know what I mean I got to
sit in the third row and you know but
physical proximity to go to go back to
your point it does matter I was there
and and I felt it so if you told me you
worked with him and he's smoking
cigarettes and flicking them at pigeons
and stuff that would be a real loss no
for the world I feel when I'm with him
like I think he's there wow yeah it's
really beautiful you know I meant to
tell you at the beginning one of the
first things I did when I found the
course and before I started reading it I
emailed a close friend around us and I
was like was ramdas into the course and
they told me that he was really into it
briefly like I don't think at the end he
would have been when I think of the
ramdas
that he was post
a stroke I'm not surprised to hear that
yeah that's what the quote was he got
really into it for a while and then when
they were writing the book walking each
other home the book about death and
dying they quote a course and I was like
that seemed like a a wink or something
and she said well this is um mirabai uh
Bush she said that was her idea but he
was very happy to put the quote in there
he seemed really lit up the course of
Miracle says it has that beautiful part
about what death will be when we're in
that enlightened place it's just taking
off a suit of clothes
um it says physical birth is not the
beginning of your life but a
continuation of your life physical death
is not an end of your life but a
continuation of your life
um when Jesus said death will be The
Last Enemy amen it's the last thing
you'll see it think of as an enemy oh
wow that's really interesting and Rhonda
used to say but he was quoting
that death is like taking off a tight
shoe which is yeah that was uh that was
a book Emmanuel yeah yeah he said that
there you go yeah I love that that's
what I was going to ask you about he's
at Birth his heart he said birth is hard
death is easy it's like taking off a
tight show it's interesting though in
correct me if I'm wrong but it seems
like the course isn't saying there's
something about like thinking death
solves anything is an illusion or like
well I think that's I don't know about a
line in the course but specifically
about that I don't I don't know nothing
I remember but definitely makes you
realize that if you leave this planet
like considering suicide you're not
going to get out of anything right right
that was a specific thing I heard Ken
give a talk about it's like that it's
not like death is the answer it's
something that we do here with our minds
that matters and when you think and
there is no death and right is what the
course says that's an illusion too
that's the self-realism and speaking of
Illusions do you think it's possible the
illusion regurgitates are you a
reincarnation person well the course of
Miracle says the value of believing
reincarnation is that reminds you that
it's more there's more going on than
right here but the negative is if you if
it makes you think so much about the
past I remember reading an original Bach
book it really became clear why are you
asking your past life your future life
would know more than your past I mean
your past life you didn't know as much
as you know now
um I if there is no time that's really
interesting
yeah yeah so what what did Marianne know
before you know talk to a future
yeah exactly well that's what one of
Richard box books is about but I think
if there is no time all our lives are
happening at once like you and I were
talking earlier and you were saying well
is it possible that imagining something
in the future is actually remembering
something in the future
um yeah the movie arrival plays with
that I don't know if you can see that
one it's it's not a spoiler but it talks
about time being circular and it kind of
plays with that I think you would really
like it but it's also do you know Rupert
Spira
he's a he's a vedanta teacher he teaches
brilliantly and beautifully very simple
stuff about
um the mind and all this is he'd love
him
um but he talks about your birth and
your death are happening simultaneously
yeah yeah it's all happening at what
time itself is the illusion yeah it's
all this moment which is kind of a Grace
don't you see like I sometimes if you
think of all of time and space and
everything that's ever happened is a
giant marble and we get to like carve
through that marble slowly you know like
a drill that's kind of a gift it would
be too overwhelming you know what I mean
um time and space are learning devices
that's what I mean they feel it feels
like a gift that we can slowly that's
what it so if I'm nice to you
like do unto others to do whatever is
doing to you why because they will why
because
In This Moment whatever you're doing is
coming back at you but time is a
learning device you're it's going to
take some time before you get that back
and see what you just did it actually
happened the moment you did it so if I
if I say something really mean to you
either you're going to say something
mean back
or you're going to be too enlightened to
go there but the court says even if you
don't I'll feel like you did I'm doing
it to myself in that moment time I'll
play out in time the experience of what
just happened but actually happened in
the moment I did it the course says if
you're thinking a judgmental thought
towards someone imagine that a sword is
falling over their head but actually
it's only falling on yours yeah wow yeah
that's interesting so when I saw Eckhart
in Reinbeck the one question I wanted to
ask seems to have been answered by the
course because it was sometimes on Val
that's my wife and I are leaving a party
we love talking [__] like that was just
something that we've always enjoyed
doing and the course seems to really be
like if I go like oh did you did you see
Marianne like her shoes or something and
like I get this charge out of it and
even if Val and I feel closer because
we're bonding over your shoes so the
example those are great shoes but like
if we do that yeah those are whatever
whatever it is Dan Levy uh but the idea
that talking [__] even though it's
Pleasant or gossiping actually is a lot
more hurtful because if if I'm making
you guilty I can't be innocent like when
I when I something I try to do is I go
Marianne is innocent you know what I
mean even if it's tempting to make fun
or whatever I'm actually declaring my
own innocence does that make sense if
I'm willing to see the beauty in you I
can see the beauty in myself right if
I'm attacking you judging you then I'm
gonna be attacking and judging myself
it's that's all you can still have fun
with people and say you saw that Green
Jacket didn't matter
you realize that did not matter right
that's interesting so you don't have to
pretend like you didn't see it well you
don't want to become some silly goody
goody you know right interesting well I
love that answer do you have an echard
story just for a selfish boy that would
love like having lunch with him what's
it like having hang out with an
enlightened person
I I respect him a lot and I
um
I just think he's someone that we all
love and respect I don't think he'd be I
mean he'd be the first person to say
let's not make me an idol here right you
know it's like I don't think that's what
the course I guess I'm just looking for
you know I didn't come to learn from my
master will watch him tie his shoes
that the expression I didn't come to
learn from my master I came to watch him
tie his shoes so one of the things like
we've been trying to have accurate on
the podcast for many years and I'm still
hopeful that it'll happen and I don't
really want to ask him about like how
the body is a gateway to the now it's
more about
sharing a moment seeing him tie his
shoes so if you've had a meal with him I
guess I wasn't looking for dirt or Dish
as much as is it like is there a
peacefulness just hanging out with
someone who's really drinking their ice
cream yes I think in the space of that
piece I think I I at times have been
with him I think maybe I felt a little
nervous or that I wanted to get it right
or uh
yes he doesn't he's a very humble man so
he there's nothing grandiose going on
there yeah you know as you know you saw
him you know the course of Miracles
talks about the difference between
grandiosity and grander and littleness
and magnitude I mean he's very humble I
think that's one of the reasons why I
think it's the real thing father Greg
Boyle if you're humble you're no you
will never stumble I don't think he made
it up but that's something he did the do
you know him he's truly wonderful father
Greg Boyle no more Industries oh yeah of
course I know who he is yes that's
beautiful I mean
yeah I know who yeah I'm not here to
throw around who's enlightened or not
but that man is truly a saint to me all
right let me just look at my notes
because I want to get we're so cold I
got to fix this heater apparently
um but this has been a nice
uh a wonderful chat I think we really
covered everything Marianne so much
I was just so pleased I listened to you
on on Oprah's pod and I was like thank
you you're such a great talker thank you
and this was a day off for me I was like
I think I can just ask anything thank
you and I'm really hopeful i i i this
isn't the Pod to announce it but like if
you run again I'd be very excited thank
you I appreciate that we'll keep your
eyes open yeah well it's it's we're
overdue thank you so thank you for
watching you as it performed knowing
what it's like to be
in hostile situations and watching you
be so solid thank you I really really
appreciate that it's um
quite a force field to pierce of course
but it's it's Noble that you're going
thank you the last couple questions we
ask
it's so funny so so many of them seem
silly have you ever seen a ghost a UFO
um no I uh remember what seeing
something that I thought was a UFO and I
got so scared and I was really laughing
at myself because I'd been saying how
excited I would be if I saw one and then
when I actually thought I saw it I was
scared what was it
I had to get a helicopter or something
right somebody told me like whenever
that SpaceX the satellite ring like
every time they're doing something all
around the country millions of not
Millions but thousands of people are
saying I saw UFO it turns out it's just
Elon Musk
I talked to a man who saw a UFO off Fire
Island there have been a lot of
sightings and he was very traumatized by
The Experience really he saw something
really serious and yeah many years ago
huh like medicine or just overwhelming
overwhelming really yeah wow yeah it was
many years ago it was someone I don't
still know but I remember hearing the
story and like he was very affected by
it like he came close to him or no it
was something he saw in the sky yeah
what was it some it was like a wall or
something I can't remember the specifics
but it but it wasn't it scared him a lot
yeah yeah oh my goodness yeah isn't that
funny the ghost too it's like it would
be so interesting to know something else
is going on but it would probably also
be very afraid I was reading about the
ghost of Lincoln in in the White House
um is that a thing yeah really yeah
um there have been sightings four more
years
that's very funny
[Laughter]
you know this series I read this um
where Lady Bird Johnson said she was
watching television she was watching in
the white house she was watching a um
um show about him and she said I felt
him over my
standing there whoa and then there was a
story about
um
many years ago
I think the queen of the then queen of
the Netherlands was in the Queen's
bedroom and the door opened she heard a
knock and then she saw him and She
fainted so what what what was happening
on some other level
um
I mean there are I I there were I
remember once it was a house
that I always passed and loved it
and there was coming a time where I was
wanting to move and I had a price in my
mind of what I was able to pay
and I looked on the internet or whatever
and the house that I had always passed
and loved was the price I could pay I
mean that was the asking price so I
could probably get it less right I was
so excited I called real estate agent I
said I want this house I want this house
this is so exciting I'm buying that
house I always pass that house so let's
go look at it this was in the middle of
the day
and um
she was talking to the other agent
and I said well I'm gonna go look around
and I went into the dining room and I
felt kind of cold and then I went
upstairs it's middle of the day
I got so scared and I ran down I said we
gotta leave we gotta leave she said well
I knew you needed to see the house
she said in 1910 or something when it
was built
they had a big party
and there were
um uh there was botulism in the olives
and several people died including
children who lived at the house oh boy
yeah so you just got overwhelmed with
fear yeah it was like a cold and and
scared I got to get out of here wow and
the realtor wasn't surprised they were
like yeah she said I knew we needed to
come say that whoa that's incredible and
terrifying what a crazy story well
energy and I mean I think they need to
do prayers in that house and staging and
everything else but yeah yeah yeah yeah
well how about this if you ever almost
died
like a near-death experience no I've had
an experience where
um I was
um on Columbus Avenue in New York with
my boyfriend and a car it was one of
those things where somebody in a car is
drunk or stoned or like completely and
the car comes up on the driveway and he
just he saw it and it just he just took
me and he pulled me back and the car
went like that so if he hadn't been
standing there that happened to me in
Times Square too yeah except I was drunk
this is I don't drink anymore alone
somebody pulled me out wow his name is
Tim I think I'm crazy crazy crazy crazy
let me ask you this is an interesting
question I'm not going to ask you if
you've ever done a hallucinogen I'm
wondering if you think a president
presidential candidate if we're at the
place yet where if you had you could say
that you did
look what I was born
no but do you think we're in a place
where you could just kind of like have
you not read my books clearly not not
all of them no I mean so do you think
that's oh yes the third wave yeah I
think the conversation is actually very
healthy what's going on in the society
today around that and of course the
legalization of marijuana means just
absurd and boiling psilocybin and pardon
yeah yeah no I think it's very healthy
what's happening yeah and helpful
potentially uh potentially absolutely I
mean that's proven now I mean we see
what's happening with a lot of the
veterans who are coming home uh
I mean I
yes I think that's far more positive
than some of the ways
that what you just went to a beautiful
place I'm like what were you about to
tell us well you know we are it's
nothing new to suggest that Americans
are medically over prescribed yes
and so I do think uh a righteous and
appropriate and now can be in so many
cases legal use of those things can be a
great Aid in fighting depression and
anxiety yeah but the greatest uh
fighting of or elimination of depression
and anxiety will be when we awaken and
develop a society in which it's just so
much easier to feel the love
um completely agree I love that what
yeah on the on Oprah's podcast you
talked about nuclear war and all these
things actually come down to fear and
love it of course they do really
policies it's people yeah and it's
making choices I mean it's insane uh if
you think about it it's just insane but
this is another the nuclear issue is
another one and we have something like 7
000 nuclear bombs in our country alone I
have one so seven keep it in the
backyard yeah
um
when you when you think about it when I
was younger we used to do these protests
ban the bomb there was such a social
movement uh supporting uh
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons
today is what you were talking about
before people just kind of accept that
and that's what concerns me about the
world today we need to wake up because
we are we've all we're all just
acquiescing it people think well there's
nothing I can do about it so we're just
going on with our lives and it's um it's
a death spiral uh humanity is on a
collision course with itself and um
the system will not disrupt itself the
status quo will not disrupt itself so I
think there's a Great Awakening going on
now and there are enough people who are
looking around and going
this is wrong this has got to stop and
no one's going to do it God cannot do
for us what he cannot do through us
yeah you're real exciting you're an
exciting person I just listening to you
now and all day and the research I've
been doing I'm just really I just hope
there's more of you coming thank you
that's so sweet of you thank you yeah
last question can you think of a time
you laughed really really hard in your
life laughed really really hard it
doesn't even have to be a good story but
it's so funny because when you first
said it and then you said when you were
a child yeah and the time I remember
laughing so hard I was not a child when
was that when was it
I was in love and I woke up and I saw
the room and I saw him and I just
started laughing and I couldn't stop
laughing what a great answer yeah just
overwhelmed with like this is right one
of those moments this is right wow is
this person still around no oh man yeah
at least you got that better to have
laughed and lost I guess uh I guess
well Marianne thank you we'll plug all
your stuff up top thank you thank you so
much we have the guests say the
catchphrase I promise you politically
and and socially it means nothing so
there's no trap here but we have the
guests say the catchphrase which is keep
it crispy so it's just how we sign off
keep it crispy yeah you could say yep
you did or say it again it's up to you
keep it crispy what a thrill thank you
thank you thank you thanks
[Music]